après le frère c'est au tour du fils de
john floyd de se rendre sur le lieu de
sa mort là où il a été asphyxié sous le
genou d'un policier se recueillir
espérant temps aucun homme ou femme
style ne devraient être forcés de vivre
sans son père et nous voulons que
justice soit faite pour ce qu'on en
attend ses fans son avocat de la famille
l'autopsié est clair les vidéos sont
accablantes et les quatre policiers
impliqués doivent payer
il termine avec un message pour les
autorités de fait votre boulot
correctement
car la planète entière bragarde bécosses
un message que semble avoir entendu les
procureurs du minnesota l'agente derek
chauvin vu ici les mains dans les poches
le genou sur le coup de john floyd et
maintenant inculpé de meurtre au second
degré les charges des mandats d'arrêt
ont aussi été émis contre les trois
autres agents inculpé de complicité est
un soulagement pour la famille mais le
gouverneur du minnesota est conscient
qu'il faut aller plus loin pour regagner
la confiance de la population
non c'est une enquête en profondeur sur
les agissements de la police de
minneapolis au cours des dix dernières
années et il invite la population à se
faire entendre
je ne crois pas qu'on aura une autre
chance de réparer les pots cassés dit il
1 le féminisme des décennies voire des
siècles de violence et d'oppression
contre les noirs du pays ont laissé des
traces profondes
jean-françois beaucoup de gens
attendaient qu'il s'exprime l'ancien
président barack obama l'a fait en fin
d'après-midi sur tous ces événements et
il a été prudent si vous savez il ya une
règle non écrite qui commande aux
anciens présidents de rester discret de
s'abstenir en fait de commenter le
travail de leurs successeurs donc barack
obama était en fait fidèle à lui-même il
s'est abstenu de dire le moindre mot
concernant dans nos jobs s'est contenté
en fait de d'offrir c'est un message de
sympathie à la famille de monsieur floyd
et puis à tous ceux qui ont été victimes
aussi de violences policières de crime
haineux
mais surtout barack obama alors ce
message aux maires de tout le pays de
toutes les états unis pour les invités à
saisir cette occasion pour réformer leur
police et pour le faire rien de plus
simple il suffit de suivre selon lui les
recommandations du rapport qu'il avait
commandé sur la police alors qu'il était
président en écoute women in de barack
obama qui s'exprimait lors d'un
séminaire sur le web
et puis dans la lch un bruit qui menacé
hier de faire intervenir l'armée dans
les grandes villes des états unis ben
aujourd'hui ça se dégonfle un peu cette
menace clairement l'homme qui menaçait
de faire appel à une vieille loi qui
date de 1807 pour traiter les cas
d'insurrection pour faire revenir
l'armée bains sont mises la défense en
quelque sorte la défense marque espère
annoncer soldat n'est pas d'accord avec
ça il l'a dit aujourd'hui tout le monde
se demandait est-ce que ça allait irrité
dans l'autre choc parce que ça allait
lui coûter son poste
ben non ce soir dans l'autre jour
pendant trois heures a finalement dit
bah pas besoin de larmes et on la garde
nationale suffit je propose écoutez donc
alors donald champions qui finalement ne
fera pas intervenir cette armée merci
beaucoup jean françois